many are still in shock here in North
Journal region and the disaster that has
unfolded in their Community
since it's the first time we've had this
much rain all of a sudden everyone is in
a daze people evacuated bare-handed
everyone is staying in the school
auditorium I'm not sure what needs to be
done
he says the area around his home looks
like an ocean with farmland and Roads
submerged in the floods this week off
intense rainfall is having a
particularly devastating event for
Farmers with more than half a million
livestock killed and tens of thousands
of hectares of Farmland damaged Lee
kyung-sik has lived here for almost 70
years now his property is lined with
uprooted crops watermelons Chili Peppers
and more
the water in my Greenhouse is up to my
shoulder the water entered my house the
rooms and all the electrical appliances
and farm machinery are unusable it's
over it's all over everything has been
ruined by this rain like many in this
area he is critical of the authorities
saying they didn't do enough to prepare
despite bad weather warnings this
monsoon season here more than 600
millimeters of rain has fallen more than
double the amount in the same period
last year
we need to fundamentally change our
disaster management system and response
methods climate change is causing
extreme natural disasters the president
has also pledged the designation of
affected areas as special disaster zones
which would help victims get
compensation and other government
support that will be welcome news for
thousands still in temporary shelters
such as this one at sunbuk elementary
school most are elderly Farmers here
they have somewhere safe to sleep hot
meals and Company but they feel anxious
about the future
formerly is also staying at a shelter
but occasionally he returns to check on
his property it's an emotional site the
destruction of his livelihood and years
of hard work he says he can't even begin
to think about what he will do next
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Exxon City
South Korea